[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about the one the only
ESCA nor a lot of you guys have notice
that we do seven deadly sins videos on
this channel and that we do fact videos
on this channel and have thus reasonably
requested that we make some seven deadly
sins facts videos so here is the first
if you want to support content like this
and praise the Sun at the same time you
can check out our s Kannur praise the
Sun t-shirt designed by pro manga artist
whose o matic
right now fans of the channel can get
25% off if you type in uproar 25 at
checkout so definitely check it out if
you're interested
link in the description anyways this is
the first in the series so if you want
to see more 7 Deadly Sins fact videos
make sure to pick up the divine acts
rita and utterly obliterate that like
button also subscribe and ring that
matching youtube bell if you want merlin
to magically transport future 7 Deadly
Sins videos straight to your phone leave
any video requests you're absolutely
burning up to see in the comments now
let's jump right into some glorious
facts fact number one let's talk about
the great ones debut he didn't directly
appear in the first volume of the manga
on page 11 we get a glimpse of his
wanted poster sketch and on page 36 we
see esken or along with the other seven
deadly sins in his armor however Eska
nor really debuted AKA we really got to
know him for the first time in the manga
side story vampires of edinburgh this
story takes place 12 years before the
main story so when elizabeth is still a
little kid vampires are released and as
you'd expect they start some trouble
ESCA noir is significantly younger and
when we first see him he's skinny with
no mustache and his clothes are way too
big and baggy for him ESCA NORs
nighttime form is as insecure and in
love with merlin as ever he even says
that he hates everything about himself
and it's or he was even born with his
curse as he cries to Melly Otis's
annoyance melioidosis stop dragging
Eskin or sacred treasure
him since s canora's nighttime form
cannot do it and Mellie Otis explains
that it's way too heavy s canora's
opponent actually turns out to be the
strongest enemy vampire the vampire King
Ezra whose power level is 4890 as we
think back to the seven deadly sins at
the beginning of the series most of them
had a power level into three thousands
and Merlin had an impressive power level
at four thousand seven hundred and ten
so this vampire king who has a power
level of almost five thousand is by no
means weak
however after s Kannur transforms into
his daytime prideful self he easily
defeats it in fact the heat coming off s
kannur when he is just standing next to
the vampire king is enough to burn him
alive it's not what you expect out of a
final fight with a boss but it is
entertaining and perfectly introduces
just how Opie this character who was a
nervous sweaty self pitying mess just a
little while ago truly is and if that
wasn't enough proof of his strength
Merlin even explains that Eskin or at
his peak level easily surpasses that of
any other sense the vampire King gets
rekt as badly as if it was Fumiko ghee
the chicken of Darkness himself facing s
Kannur and his super effective sunshine
ability s kannur made his anime debut in
the signs of a holy war OVA where we
briefly see his nighttime skinny form a
short moment that nevertheless made all
of us manga fans go absolutely crazy
fact number 2's Kannur just like King
Arthur and Melly Otis comes from
Arthurian legend knockabout the creator
of the seven deadly sins is no doubt
inspired by different elements of our 30
and legend but he always mixes these
elements and then puts his own spin on
it
in Arthurian legend there are two
notable Eskin ores
Eskin or LeGrande or Eskin or large who
was supposedly raised by a giant in a
witch and is as his name suggests
supposed to be a very large man the
seven deadly sins
ESCA nor is usually thought to be based
on this s Kannur because he was said to
grow stronger until noon and then his
strength would begin to diminish after
that very much like Eskin or from the
series and we've definitely seen him
grow to a huge stature in this year
Gawain King Arthur's nephew and a knight
of the round table was also set to share
the same power as Eskin or both of their
powers grew and waned with the Sun here
is an example of how the ability is
described in Arthurian legend the two
knights fought with swords and shields
at first Gawain proved to be the
stronger night as the Sun rose higher
and higher at each hour as the Sun
passed its Zenit and slowly drew nearer
to evening Gawain strength decreased as
each hour passed so Gawain was weak as
an ordinary man and quote and if you're
wondering Gawain forfeited the fight
because he knew he couldn't win without
his son enhanced powers there was also
another eScan or in Arthurian legend he
was king of the white mountain and the
nephew of Eskin or the large he was also
referred to as Eskin or the handsome now
I don't think we have to say that the
Eska nor from the manga is purely one or
the other rather we can view him as a
combination of these two Eskin ores
since our Eskin or especially in his
prideful form would also consider
himself to be handsome and the Eskin ore
from the series also comes from royalty
although he was chased away for being a
monster before he could even have a
chance to become king another reference
to Arthurian legend is the name of esken
or sacred treasure the divine axe Rita
Rita Garth was actually the strongest
and most violent of all giants in
ancient time the story goes that there
were many kings back in that time and
while they fought each other Giants
would emerge from mountain caves and
raid their territories Rita was like why
do I have to settle for stealing some
sheep when I'm stronger braver and
bigger than these weak human Kings he
fought against many kings and always
shaved off their beards the symbol of
their strength and manliness
he wove their kingly beards into his
cloak as proof of his strength and
victory one day 28 kings of Prydain
joined forces to take Rita out but he
beat them and added all of their beards
to his cloak and then declared himself
the king of all pride a already I think
we can cska NORs own great strength size
and pride reflected in this giant Rita
asked nor even has facial hair now a
mustache to show off his manliness and
surprise surprise Rita the joy
did not get along well with King Arthur
just like esken or doesn't like Arthur
in the series because he is jealous of
how much Merlin cares about him
Rita wanted Arthur to cut off his beard
so he could add it to his bloody cloak
which was now thick with the beers
undefeated kings but Arthur was like not
gonna happen so they fought and arthur
managed to defeat this insanely strong
giant king although the axe Rita is set
to get its name from a young maiden who
was loved by the son in the manga it is
nonetheless interesting to explore the
clear parallels between s kannur and
arena from Arthurian legend it's fun
looking at how these legends are
filtered into the seven deadly sins let
me know in the comments if you notice
any other cool parallels between the
seven deadly sins and Arthurian legend I
would love to learn about some new ones
fact number three you may have noticed
that Eskin oars daytime form is jacked
AF well let me shed new light on why
that might be
let's look at an interview with the
creator of the seven deadly sins naka
bouzouki in the interview he said the
first manga I ever bought was dr. slump
by Akira Toriyama when I was in
elementary school and junior high I was
really into ultimate muscle Fist of the
North Star and Dragon Ball I love
drawing muscles now because of those
three manga and quote Melly Otis has
some muscles as does bond but these
muscles are nothing compared to the
muscles we see on s Canora
so you can bet that knock'em especially
loves drawing the insanely muscular
esken or it is no surprise that
knockabout got inspiration from
Dragonball since many Shawn and mangakas
did the combat class aspect of seven
deadly sins is very similar to the power
levels in Dragon Ball - and let's just
say that ESCA Norris is over 9000 in the
interview naka ba also nodded towards s
Kannur who had yet to make his
appearance at that point the interviewer
said there hasn't been much revealed yet
about some members of the seven deadly
sins why is that
and knockabout answered maybe it's
because they're too strong maybe you'll
find out soon enough and quote s kannur
was last to be introduced but definitely
not least Makabe did not disappoint and
the last introduced indefinitely turned
out to be insanely strong strong enough
to justify in Aqaba
to town on his muscles fact number four
let's talk about some fan theories there
were two fan theories about Eskin or
that eventually turned out to be true
the first almost a theory about his
glasses people guessed that s canora's
glasses allowed him to be in his
nighttime form during the day since
nighttime s Kannur seemed to be wearing
them at times that could not have been
at night people found this to be
suspicious and eventually they were
proved right the glasses were given to
him by Merlin and they effectively
suppress his daytime form however if
they are removed during the day he will
instantly transform into his glorious
daytime form let me just take this
moment to point out that s Canora kinda
reminds me of Superman since they both
get their power from the Sun are
overpowered muscular dudes and have a
less cool alter ego that wears glasses
so they are very similar but you can bet
I definitely prefer Eskin or unlike go
Thurs s canora's glasses are not
prescription so he can see fine without
them fans also speculated that s Kannur
son based powers were related to the
goddess clan and this was proven to be
true when s canora's ability sunshine
was revealed to be a special blessing
called a grace that was once wielded by
my L the strongest Archangel fact number
five believe it or not s Kannur was not
going to be the sin of pride originally
the sin of pride was going to go to a
fairy Prince called Jahan s kannur was
going to be the sin of lust
he was extremely ripped and considering
he was going to get the sin of lust he
was also going to be portrayed as a
horndog but it seems that his horndog
tendencies were passed on to Mellie Otis
his overall look was different too from
the one that we know and love he was
originally supposed to have a younger
clean-shaven appearance and was similar
to Gris amore
however thankfully we got that glorious
sun praising mustache and he ended up
being the opposite of a horndog instead
when it comes to love he is usually a
shy guy who has deep feelings for Merlin
and is extremely loyal to her despite
the fact that at this point his love
seems unrequited I still can't believe
he was close to being the son of lust
though since he has grown to fit the
pride
roll also perfectly knock up was
probably like s Kanuri gonna be a sin of
loss and s Kunal is like who decided
that I choose my own sin and I will
choose pride and that was the end of
that fact number six let's talk about s
canora's age he was born on July 1st and
is 40 years old when the manga starts
meaning he was around 28 years old
during the vampires of Edinburgh
side-story although he physically
appears to be the oldest member of the
seven deadly sins ironically he is
actually the youngest sin since everyone
else either age is slowly compared to a
human or doesn't age anymore so this 40
year old man is actually the baby of the
groom fact number seven next let's take
a closer look at s canora's power as was
already mentioned knockabout kept s
kannur for last in part because he is so
powerful in the vampire of edinburgh
side story
merlin did not hesitate to state that at
his peak he easily surpassed every other
cent in power his powers fluctuate more
than anyone elses since his power grows
and wanes with the Sun but let's look at
every power level that was given for him
his night time form was recorded at
15:00 which is actually the lowest power
level revealed in the entire series
however things look brighter into
daytime as we'll see ESCA noir was also
measured at 28,000 and the interesting
thing about this instance is that he
transforms not because of the Sun but
because go thir makes him think of
Merlin who according to us can or is the
very Sun itself what a poet this guy is
probably the most jackpoet in history so
s kannur can in fact transform without
the actual sun under certain
circumstances his power level was also
measured as the sun rose when he was
fighting gal and it was measured to be
50,000th and 55 and 60 and then Merlin
stopped calling out the quickly rising
power level then later when he is
fighting Millie Otis in assault mode his
power level at one moment is measured at
114 thousand however at his strongest we
have not been given a specific power
level and according to the guidebook
there is a reason for this the guidebook
suggests that his power is unmeasurable
at its peak
in the manga Merlin even says he is
invincible in this form so I'm not
saying that his true power level when
he's at his strongest is infinity but
I'm not not saying it either fact number
8 in the Japanese the great s Kannur is
voiced by a 38 year old tomokazu sugita
this very talented voice actor or say
you worked on some of my favorite shows
for instance he was kion in The
Melancholy of Haruhi Suzumiya and he was
yuuichi in Kanaan to mention only a few
of his roles in the 2009 and 2010 anime
grand prix the winners for favored male
character work Ian from Haruhi Suzumiya
and Kentucky Socata from Gintama
respectively both of who were voiced by
sugita in 2009
sugita also won Best Supporting Actor at
the third seiyu Awards fact number nine
in the English dub s kannur is voiced by
the 49 year old Kyle Hebert he actually
voiced other characters in season 1 of
the anime including Gillis dad a member
of dawn roar and the doctor who tried to
poison his own demon patient it is also
noteworthy that Kyle voiced another
mustache wearing axe wielding muscle man
he voiced Batra who is a fearless
warrior from the game Fire Emblem Heroes
he's described as having an impressive
physical bulk for this character only
building up his attack really matters
because it improves his one-shot damage
which is his greatest strength that
definitely reminds me of Eska Norse Opie
abilities that can one-shot practically
anyone when he is at his strongest Kyle
also won an award in 2009 at Anime Expo
for best english voice actor for his
role as kameena in guten logon that's
right he shares a voice with the paragon
of masculinity as if esken or wasn't
already manly an epic enough among other
characters he also voiced my favorite
character in Dragon Ball Z teen Gohan
and the dog sniffer
Keva from Naruto fact number 10 we have
made it to the zenith of the video and
that calls for a praise the Sun round so
instead of just one fact I will state as
many facts as I can in a short window
time three-two-one praise the Sun esken
or like snapping and writing poetry his
favorite food changes he prefers to me
during the day and vegetables during the
night
I feel like meat is always associated
with manliness just look at the manly
Metapod from class 1-a Eskin ors height
also varies he goes from being 165
centimeters over 5 foot 5 inches tall to
being 325 centimeters or 10 foot 8
inches tall his weight goes from being
48 kilograms or 108 pounds to being 355
kilograms or 785 pounds and I think we
can definitely see that change in his
muscles the guide book also tells us
that his charming point is his shyness
that he regrets being born that the most
embarrassing thing in his life is his
noon self that what he wants most right
now is to control his powers and that
his favorite scent is wild berry every
sin has their animal symbol on their
body but Eska Knorr is the largest in
proportion to his own body lastly there
is a YouTube channel that I'll link in
description where they actually recreate
Eska Knorr divine acts Rita in real life
and it looks awesome you can even see a
man in full Eskin or cosplay using the
divine axe to cut a watermelon talk
about overkill and that is it for
today's video
thank you so much for watching I really
appreciate it
Ray's the divine axe Rita and bring it
down on that like button if you enjoy
the video and want to see more like it
leave video suggestions you're
absolutely burning up to see in the
comments and finger stab that subscribe
button and bring that magic YouTube
Belle and the lovely Merlyn will
teleport future deadly sins videos
straight to your phone if you want to
support more content like this and
praise the Sun while you're at it you
can check out our praise the Sun esken
or shirt at Anime uproar calm link in
the description so the story behind this
is that we originally wanted anime
shirts that look cool AF for ourselves
but couldn't find good options online so
we got a pro manga artist kizomba d to
create original designs from our
favorite animes and now along with us
you too can share in Eskin or
glory and praise the Sun all day long
with your very own s Canora praise the
Sun t-shirt for fans of the channel you
can use uproar 25 at checkout to get 25
percent off your order
anyways thanks so much for your ongoing
support and until next time see you
space cowboy
[Music]